how are you greeting héctor mejía with his
brief informative for today monday
march 29 we begin with a news item in
development a suspect is detained
for allegedly causing several
fires in second-hand stores
east of the valley
this time the firefighters reported that it
happened in a  store located on
bulls ten at around seven o'clock at night
no one was injured but the
property damage reaches 100 thousand dollars
meanwhile a woman accused of
killing her stepson appears in
court again state lic of 29
years was arrested in  January
arrest report says she hit the
4-year-old boy and hit his head on the
ground when he wasn't eating or unresponsive
a judge is expected today to decide if there is
enough evidence to proceed to a
trial
a new center is opened  In
general, vaccination will be tomorrow
at the Sunseri community center, where you
can administer up to 800 daily doses. It
will only open from Tuesday to  Friday
from 8 in the morning to 2 in the afternoon and if you
need to make an appointment for more
information visit our page
kirchner dotcom diagonal in Spanish and
now we go to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny day with
temperatures reaching 80 degrees
however the  winds to the
valley tonight and they will remain until
tomorrow have a nice day I am héctor
mejía and this was your brief informative
jing zhao in spanish
[Music]